oh so this chair is not very stable
we've used this chair in a project that
we called the other kind of sleep
paralysis inspired media installation
the experience the question was what is
called sleep paralysis this is something
that happens as you just just fall
asleep or just just wake up so your body
is paralyzed but your eyes can open and
you may start hallucinating in all the
different modalities could be visual
could be auditory could be tactile could
be pressure on your chest and one of the
most distinctive feelings that people
get is a feeling of presence of
something animal not necessarily human
in the room somehow watching them or
having an evil intention towards them so
we basically took a study that I did
before in a dream a nightmare laboratory
where we collected hundreds of
descriptions of the presence episodes
and we've tried to use the elements like
for example what kind of sounds the
people here some people describe
electrical buzzing some people describe
sounds of steps some people describe
furniture moving we create a little room
where we wanted people to have a feeling
of presence in the room wisdom so we
wanted to intentionally try to make them
comfortable at the same time and
destabilize them a little bit and then
ask them did they at some point feel
that somebody was there in the room
wisdom and in many occasions they would
localize like yes somebody was walking
behind me and sometimes they would tell
the whole story like I felt it was a
little boy you know gently step
what chair
you